Der Rasenfunk – Kurzpass. In der Ligue 1 ist schon wieder so einiges passiert. Sieben Spieltage sind schon gespielt. Wir wollen drauf blicken zusammen mit David Frogier de Ponlevoy von 93. Schön, dass du mit dabei bist. Ich hoffe, du verzeihst mir den kleinen, da habe ich den ersten Namenshauptler schon im Intro drin.
Ja, wir haben gerade schon über Namen gesprochen. Er wartet nichts, Leute. Ich werde ausländische Spieler französisch aussprechen und vielleicht sogar einige Franzosenfalsen aussprechen, weil ich sie nur in der Zeitung gelesen habe.
Das Gute ist, du hast ja mich als Gegenpart und der schafft es ja nicht mal, seinen Gast ordentlich anzukündigen. Deswegen schön, dass du da bist, David, und mach dir keinen Kopf wegen deiner Namen. Wir wuscheln uns da irgendwie durch.
Genau. Hallo, lieber Max, hallo, liebe Hörerinnen, hallo, lieber Hörer. Schön, dass ich da bin.
Wir wollen heute über die Ligue 1 sprechen. Und da ist neben dem Platz fast genauso viel passiert wie auf dem Platz. Und ausnahmsweise drehen wir mal das Rasenfunkprinzip um und gucken erst neben dem Platz und dann auf dem Platz. David, hol uns mal rein. Es war einiges los auf den Rängen in der französischen Liga. Was ist denn da passiert?
Ich nehme an, du spielst auf die Homophobie-Debatte an. Großes Thema. Ja, also ich glaube, was man mitbekommen hat in Deutschland ist, oder was man vielleicht mitbekommen haben könnte in Deutschland, ist, dass Spiele abgebrochen worden sind wegen homophober Gesänge. Das war zuerst nur ein Zweitliga-Spiel. Da haben sich auf Social Media dann einige Franzosen gleich markiert. Na ja, in der 2. Liga machen sie es, in der 1. Liga trauen sie es sich bestimmt nicht. Und in den folgenden Wochen wurden Spiele zumindest kurzfristig unterbrochen. Das basiert, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, auf einer Vorgabe der UEFA. Die Liga hat daraus so ein eigenes Reglement gemacht in drei Schritten. Das heißt, du kannst einen Stopp von weniger als fünf Minuten einlegen, du kannst dann einen Stopp von bis zu 20 Minuten einlegen und du kannst im dritten Fall einen kompletten Spielerabbruch machen. Das ist bisher noch nicht passiert. Was passiert ist, sind eben diese Stops von fünf Minuten, wo dann die Leute aufgefordert worden sind, das bitte zu unterlassen. Und das hat eine auf mehrfacher Ebene unglaubliche Debatte ausgelöst und ist auch ein, naja, ist schon ein schwieriges Thema. Weil einerseits kann man sagen, oder würde ich auch sagen uneingeschränkt, Homophobie hat nichts zu suchen im Stadion. Es ist schön, dass da eigentlich noch was unternommen wird gegen. Es ist durchaus so, dass es in Frankreich viel zu sehr folklore geworden ist, dass viel zu viele Gesänge gewisse diskriminierende Begriffe einfach, naja, gedankenlos benutzen im Grunde. Aber gerade dadurch ja auch dazu beitragen, dass sich gewisse Vorteile verfestigen. Insofern Applaus, dass das angegangen wird. Das Problem ist, dass – also Fans sind ja nicht dumm und die haben jetzt angefangen, ein veritables Katz-und-Maus-Spiel zu machen. Also im Grunde gab es jetzt noch mehr homophobe Begriffe als früher, weil sie halt versucht haben, dann loben wir noch mal die Grenzen aus und schauen mal und machen ein paar neckige Wortspiele oder verpacken irgendwelche Worte irgendwie so in irgendwelchen Spruchbändern. Das ist ja eigentlich nicht so richtig, aber dann doch. Und dann können wir die Liga mal schön provozieren und dann muss der Schiedsrichter abbrechen, dann sind ja eh noch 5 Minuten, dann machen wir weiter. So, das heißt, man kann sich ein bisschen die Frage nach dem Sinn stellen. Du hast da natürlich die Politik, die mit eingreift. Du hast eine Sportministerin, die auch dankenswerterweise Partei ergreift, sagt, es ist richtig so. Dann hast du den Präsidenten der Liga, der die Sportministerin bespöttelt und sagt, naja, die ist ehemalige Schwimmerin und im Schwimmbecken kommt sowas halt nicht vor. Im Fußball sei das normal. Viele schwulen Verbände haben gesagt, es ist richtig und wichtig, dass das Thema angesprochen wird. Andere haben auch gesagt, naja, so ein bisschen, oder einige mahnen auch, naja, mit diesem Hammer drauf macht jetzt auch ein bisschen die Arbeit kaputt, die wir jetzt die vergangenen Jahre gemacht haben, weil eigentlich provoziert das alle nur.
Klar, wenn jetzt Spruchbänder auftauschen, wo man versucht, sich möglichst geistreich genau um den beleidigten Begriff herum zu formulieren, aber ihn ja dann letztlich doch im Subtext die ganze Zeit auf einem transparent hochhält, dann kann man das schon nachvollziehen.
Und der Schwere kommt halt hinzu, dass viele Fans und gerade Ultra-Gruppen sich ohnehin von der Politik starke Gängel fühlen in den letzten Jahren. Unter anderem wegen der Ausfahrtsfahrten, die sind vor einigen Jahren unter diversen Ausnahmeregelungen, also es war ja mal der Ausnahmezustand ausgerufen worden in Frankreich, und in dem Zuge haben sie das auch genutzt, um Auswärtsfahrten einzuschränken, weil sie auch eh sagten, der Gelbfesten und so, Polizisten sind anderweitig beschäftigt. Oder jetzt vor ein paar Wochen war ja G7-Gipfel in Frankreich, da wurden auch Spiele umgelegt und Polizei konnte nicht vor Ort sein, etc. etc. Und insgesamt ist eine Kultur entstanden in Frankreich, wo viele Auswärtsfans ständig rechnen damit müssen, dass die Fahrten ihnen in die Stadt XY untersagt werden, weil O könnte ja Hochrisikospiel sein. Und das wird sehr, sehr nonchalant benutzt mittlerweile. Und Ultras müssen sich, keine Ahnung, dann am Spieltag zu Hause melden bei der Polizeifreudpräfektur oder ansonsten riskieren sie Strafen und all solche Schikaden. Das heißt, viele Fans haben eh gerade das Gefühl, dass die Politik sie sehr gängelt, jetzt aber sagt, na ja, aber jetzt gängelt bitte keine Randgruppen und dann sagen halt, Ultras, wir sind aber auch gerade hier eine Randgruppe. Und als jemand, der selbst auch Fußball liebt und auch durchaus Fan-Kultur liebt, kann ich das einerseits verstehen, es ist eine unschöne Menge Lage. Trotzdem bin ich klar dafür, dass man Homophobie einschränkt und dass man auch als Fan kapiert, dass man die gegnerische Mannschaft auch beleidigen kann, ohne gleichzeitig noch eine Minderheit zu diskriminieren.
Aber sag mir kurz, da haben wir ja sowieso, wir zwei hier kommen ins Netz und hoffentlich auch alle Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen werden da mit übereinstimmen. Gleichzeitig merkt man schon, da verquicken sich jetzt verschiedene Probleme und das eine ist da nicht mehr vom anderen zu trennen. Aber weil du das vorhin einmal so angedeutet hast, dass Homophobie in der französischen Gesellschaft und durchaus auch in den Staaten schon immer noch präsenter sei, als jetzt zum Beispiel hier in Deutschland, wie sind denn da die Ultra-Gruppierungen aufgestellt, wo wir in Deutschland ja schon im breiten Konsens der allerallermeisten Ultra-Gruppierungen einen Konsens haben, der sich gegen die Diskriminierung von Minderheiten und damit eben auch gegen Homophobie richtet. Ist es in Frankreich ähnlich oder unterscheidet sich da Frankreich von Deutschland?
Ich glaube schon, dass das Bewusstsein gefehlt hat. Also ich muss dazu immer noch einschrecken sagen, ich lebe in Deutschland. Insofern habe ich den Puls nicht ganz so an der Fußballkultur in Frankreich wie sogar an der in Deutschland. Aber mein Eindruck ist durchaus, dass das Bewusstsein bislang gefehlt hat. Insofern ist die Debatte vermutlich doch wiederum richtig und wichtig. Und dass wir da in Deutschland schon auch einen Schritt weiter sind und vermutlich – ich meine, es ist ja eine Sache, ob einzelne Leute irgendwas reinbrüllen oder ob eben Ultras gewisse Begriffe in ihre Fangesänge einbauen, um eben gezielt den Gegner zu beleidigen.
Ja, würde ich auch sagen.
Genau. Und das ist, würde ich schon sagen, ist in Deutschland deutlich zurückgegangen und in Frankreich eben tatsächlich noch nicht.
Nein. Dann bin ich gespannt, wie sich das jetzt in den kommenden Monaten entwickelt. Jetzt gerade ist halt einfach alles sehr hochgekocht und da legt immer die jeweilige Gegenseite noch mal einen drauf. Ich bin sehr gespannt, was du mir dann in ein paar Monaten erzählst zu diesem Thema. Da bleiben wir dran. Jetzt wollen wir aber auch mal auf Sportliche gucken. Und als ein alter weißer Mann freue ich mich an allem, was konstant ist, was sich nicht verändert. Und deswegen bin ich ganz froh, dass in der Tabelle, in der sich sehr viel verändert hat, eine Konstante noch gleichgeblieben ist, nämlich PSG als Tabellenführer. Gott sei Dank. Daran kann ich mich jetzt festhalten, David.
Aber knapp, aber knapp.
Ja, Punkt gleich. Ja, Punkt gleich. Zwei Niederlagen schon nach sieben Spielen.
Wie ist die Lage? Liga Pouille, Europa Houille ist die Lage bei Paris. Also zwei Niederlagen nach sieben Spielen ist krass. Vor allen Dingen gegen Wien. Also gut gegen Rennes vielleicht okay, aber jetzt gegen Reims, gerade unter der englischen Woche vor zwei Tagen. Ist jetzt schon nochmal ein Ausrufezeichen.
Auch nur 12 Tore erzielt. Der aktuelle beste Torschütze in der Liga für PSG ist Eric Maxim Schuppo-Moting.
Mist, genau. Das wollte ich noch als kleinen Gag einbauen, ob du den aktuell besten Torschützner raten kannst. Schuppo-Moting ist tatsächlich der aktuell beste Torschütze.
Ich habe meine Hausaufgaben gemacht, David. Woran liegt es, wenn wir jetzt kurz auf die Liga gucken? Dann würde ich gerne noch kurz über dieses Champions-League-Spiel gegen Real Madrid sprechen. Definitiv schießt PSG weniger Tore als in der letzten Saison. Aktuell sind es in Anführungszeichen nur 12 nach sieben Spielen. Man hat zwar nur vier Gegentreffer kassiert, aber das sind dann jeweils auch entscheidende Tore. Man hat gegen Real diese beiden Gegentreffer zu Hause kassiert, 0 zu 2 verloren und eben vorher auch schon die zweite Niederlage. Mussten wir kurz noch mal helfen, das war…
Gegenrennen.
Genau, gegenrennen. Also liegt es jetzt an der Offensive und daran, dass man hinten jetzt Pech hatte, immer dann die entscheidenden Gegentreffer kassiert zu haben oder liegt es an der Neymar-Diskussion? Es gibt ja so viele mögliche Ansätze. Liegt es an Thomas Tuchel? Wo würdest du jetzt mal den Finger drauflegen und sagen, deiner Ansicht nach ist das so ein bisschen das Hauptproblem.
An allem. Aber gegen Reims liegt es an der B-Mannschaft. Also, das muss man auch nochmal klar sagen. Da war ein junger Mbessault, da war Kursawa als Außenverteidiger, Paré des Herrera, Sarabia, Bernhard hat im Mittelfeld gespielt irgendwie.
Ja gut, wenn Bernhard spielt, dann geht ja sowieso gar nichts. Ich als süddeutsches Medium.
Also zu Saisonbeginn hatte ich das Gefühl, Tuchel war extrem angezählt. Weil dieser Niederlage gegen Rennes kam auch ziemlich früh. Und eigentlich hatte er alle Transfers bekommen, die er wollte. Es begann ja erst mal, ein Jahr davor hat er immer wieder sich beschwert, dass er eigentlich nicht den richtigen Kader hat. Dem fehlt ein Sechser. Er hat seinen Sechser bekommen mit Gay. Er hat mit Herr Rarabia Diallo die T-Film-Kader, die er jetzt braucht. Er hat sogar noch etwas überraschend Ekadi abgestaubt. Also ich weiß nicht, ob er. Ziemlich sicher nicht er, sondern der neue Sportdirektor Leonardo. Und sie haben endlich einen souveränen, starken Torhüter mit Navas, wofür sie Arreola abgeschoben haben. Wo ich auch zumindest mal ein Fragezeichen setzen würde und sagen würde, sie haben ihr eigenes Talent eigentlich ein bisschen stiefmütig behandelt. Viel zu lange. Also da hätten sie Arreola mal deutlich besser vertrauen können auch.
Und sie haben ja Neymar behalten. Also sieht das ja auch auf das Spiel danach aus, als wäre der Kader vor allem breiter geworden. Und in der Offensive hat man mit Icardi definitiv noch jemand sehr gut mit dazu bekommen. Mit Sahabian eine gute Verbreiterung der Breite, wollte ich gerade sagen.
Verbreiterung der Breite, genau.
Und Neymar ja noch gehalten. Bei allen Quereen hin und her ist er ja immer noch gar kein so schlechter Fußballer.
Ne, ich meine, das war ja auch ein unglaubliches Geschacher im Sommer. Also ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir das noch ganz kurz aufgreifen sollen, so im Schnelldurchlauf.
Ich drücke dir die Daumen.
Ich versuch's mal. Also es begann ja damit, dass das Ende der letzten Saison für Neymar extrem schlecht lief, auch aus persönlichen Gründen. Er hat ja im Pokalfinale gegen Rennes, das war ich sehr verantwortlich, einen Fan geurfeigt aus Rennes. Quatsch, nicht im Pokalfinale, eher in Rennes. Also einen Fan aus Rennes hat er geurfeigt. Dann gab es diese Vergewaltigungsvorwürfe. Und dann hat Messi angefangen, ihn zu bewerben offenbar. Und dann war halt so dieses Gefühl, ich fühle euch bei ihm, Liga taugt nichts, Liga ist so physisch, er will gern woanders hin. Er hat auch immer wieder schön betont, dass er der größte sportliche Erfolg seines Lebens, diese Remontada, Barcelona gegen Paris war, ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so ganz die beste Möglichkeit, um dich bei deinen eigenen Fans beliebt zu machen, wenn du sagst, der größte Erfolg deiner Karriere war die größte Niederlage, die sie jemals erlebt haben oder gefühlt.
Das ist so ein bisschen, als würde David Luiz als Spieler vom FC Bayern sagen, ja, also ich muss sagen, Geißespiel meiner Karriere, damals, Finale d'Orham, das war natürlich mir.
Genau, Finale d'Orham. So, und dann hat im Juni Paris überraschend erstmals signalisiert, okay, gut, also wenn er gehen will, dann soll er gehen. Dann hat man auch schon gemerkt, dass da eben, fand ich jetzt, war auch ein Hinweis darauf, dass da eben auch ein neuer, starker Mann am Ruder ist mit Leonardo, der ja damals der beherrschende Faktor 2011, 2013 schon einmal war und der sich jetzt wirklich auch etabliert hat als der neue Chef im Ring und der klar gesagt hat, gut, wenn er gehen will, kann er gehen, aber eben nicht unter Einkaufswert. 222 Millionen. Und dann begann ein unglaubliches Geschacher, weil Barcelona ja eigentlich kein Geld hat, nach dem Einkauf von Grießmann und der Jong. Und dann wurden, weiß ich nicht, Spieler hin und her verschoben oder geplant. Also so Tabellen gezeichnet hier. Ihr kriegt den, wenn ihr den nehmt. Zwei, drei Mittelfeldspieler gegen einen Neymar und so ein Zeug.
Das war ein bisschen wie bei Siedler. Ich tausche drei Holz gegen zwei Schaf.
Zwei Lehm, genau. Absolut unglaublich.
Leg noch ein Dembélé drauf dann.
Dembélé wurde noch nicht mal gefragt. Das war die letzte Phase der Verhandlungen. Da hat Barca Spieler vorgeschlagen, ohne sie gefragt zu haben. Neymar hat noch gesagt, ich zahle auch 20 Minuten selbst, den Herr Volt. Dann hat Neymars Umfeld anscheinend noch Madrid kontaktiert. Dann hat sich noch Juve eingeschaltet. Alle haben Wildspieler durch die Gegend geworfen, aber immer mit Fantasiepreisen. Paris hat teilweise gesagt, wir wollen die gar nicht unbedingt. Und so hoch wie ihr die einen schätzt, sind die für uns gar nicht. Wir haben da keinen Druck. Wir wollen ihr nicht hergeben. Also kurz und gut am Ende ist er geblieben. Er ist von den Fans ausgefiffen worden. Er ist ziemlich stark. Bis er dann in den letzten zwei Spielen, also jetzt vor dieser Reims-Niederlage, zwei Last-Minute-1-0-Siege erzielt hat, in Neymar's Deal, eins gegen Straßburg, eins gegen Lyon. Und jetzt war gegen Reims zumindest wieder Ruhe. Also kann man halt auch nicht argumentieren, wenn der Star dann das 1-0 noch serviert.
Und zwischendurch war ja dann auch dieses 13-0 gegen Real, was sich ja auch geholfen hat, die Stimmung zu bessern, auch wenn Neymar da jetzt noch kein Teil der Veranstaltung war. Aber das war ja auch eine durchaus überzeugende Leistung mit diesem 3-0, wo man zwar auch sehr effizient war, aber Real hatte keinen einzigen Torschuss. Alle zehn Schüsse gingen neben das Tor. Und PSG hat aus seinen fünf Torschüssen drei Tore gemacht.
Ja, aber es war auch großartig. Es war auch tatsächlich ein Trainer-Sieg. Alle Spieler haben anschließend gesagt, sie seien großartig von Tuchel eingestellt worden. Er hat bewusst offenbar gesagt, dass die Achter gepresst werden sollen von Madrid. Er hat Gey auf die Acht nach vorne geschoben. Die Maria hat unglaublich gearbeitet. Das war der eine Punkt, wo ich echt dachte, jetzt kommt die Wende. Weil zu Saisonbeginn wirkte Tuchel total schlapp. Er schien komplett das Vertrauen in sein Spielercoaching verloren zu haben. Er hat gefühlt kaum noch was verändert. Er hat positionstreu gewechselt. Er hat taktische Aufstellen laufen lassen. Gegen Rennes wurde er ausgecoacht, würde ich sagen, von seinem Gegner Stefan, den wir auch schon ausführlich gelobt haben. Und Cavani soll anschließend genervt gefragt haben, warum denn Mbappé nicht pressen muss und alle anderen pressen müssen und so. Also da schien einiges im Argen. Er scheint diese Unstimmigkeiten, die es da gegeben hat, in der Rückrunde zwischen Franzosen und Brasilianen im Team, nicht so richtig in den Griff zu bekommen. Es wird ihm oft vorgeworfen, dass er seinen Stars zu viel durchgehen lässt. Es gibt einen absurden Streit noch um die Physios und das medizinische Team, weil es wurden neue Leute geholt, ohne dass Tuchel konsultiert wurde. Wobei er letzte Saison selbst versucht hat, neue Physios und Mediziner zu etablieren. Und tatsächlich haben sie extrem viele Verletzungen zu Beginn der Saison gehabt. Cavani war verletzt, Diallo war verletzt, Kehrer war verletzt, Draxler. Aktuell sind Icardi und Cavani verletzt. Es gab dann sogar eine ganz wunderbare Sache. Es gab sogar eine Diskussion um den Greenkeeper. Es wird endlich mal Zeit für die Rasen vom Greenkeeper vollgemacht. Wem sagst du das?
Ich schicke, ohne Namen zu nennen, eine Grüße hinaus. Ich warte noch auf eine E-Mail.
Im Grieche wurde mir vorgeworfen, dass er den Rasen im Stadion-Top hat, aber den Rasen auf den Trainingsplätzen nicht mehr hat.
Aber da wir ja auch noch über andere Teams sprechen wollen, versuche ich dann mal zusammenzufassen. Das wirkt auf mich wie im Grunde genau das, was man erwarten kann, wenn man so viele sehr selbstbewusste Fußballstars in ein Team packt, ihnen einen sehr ehrgeizigen Trainer zur Seite stellt und gleichzeitig in einer Liga spielt, in der der Titel wenig wert ist. Das wirkt, wie auf allen Ecken stehen da Pulverfässer und an manchen brennt vielleicht die Lunte schon. Dann hast du zwar einen sehr guten Kader, du hast eine sehr gute Offensive und der Theorie nach auch eine sehr gute Defensive. Du hast deine Highlightspiele, wie unter anderem gegen Real. In der Liga wackelst du aber. Es gibt Unstimmigkeiten innerhalb des Teams. Es gibt Fragezeichen rund um den Trainer. Und das Umfeld ist jetzt auch nicht gerade ruhig, nachdem der wichtigste Spieler gesagt hat, ich möchte eigentlich weg und jetzt doch irgendwie geblieben ist. Also sprich über PSG werden wir, glaube ich, noch häufiger sprechen in der Saison. Und das ist alles andere als ruhig gerade.
Also ich glaube, dass sich die Eier schaukeln werden in der Liga hindurch. Und vermutlich, da kommen wir dann gleich noch dazu, dass es auch schaffen werden, weil sich aktuell kein richtiger Herausforderer zeigt. Und es wird wie immer bei Paris, und was Tuchel ja auch wusste, es wird um diese Champions-League-Saison gehen. Und wenn er da das halten kann, was er im Material zeigt, dann ist vermutlich auch egal, was er in der Liga macht. Champions League ist halt trotzdem auch ein Vabancspiel. Müssen wir nicht drüber diskutieren, da kannst du dann doch auch noch mal gegen sonst wen rausfliegen. Im Viertelfinale. Also das wird alles sehr, sehr spannend. Allerdings wurde angekündigt, auch im Zuge dieser Physio-Debatte habe ich mitbekommen, dass die Spieler möglichst ihren Peak im Frühjahr erreichen sollen. Es soll jetzt extra darauf hintrainiert werden, dass die Spieler eher im Frühjahr fit sind.
Mann, das ist ein tolles Signal an die Liga.
Wahnsinn, ne?
Galatasaray und Brügge sind neben Real die weiteren Gegner in der Champions League, um mal die richtigen Gegner zu nennen. Der Rest ist es ja ganz offensichtlich nicht. Wobei, wenn ich mir angucke, da sind immerhin interessante Namen dabei, nämlich zum Beispiel auf Platz 2 aktuell mit der identischen Bilanz zu PSG, nämlich 5-7 und 2 Niederlagen, Angers. Wie kommen die denn dahin? Was zur Hölle machen die da? Und wie lange werden die da bleiben?
Ich schicke einen Satz voraus, als ich mich jetzt vorbereitet habe, auf den Rasenfunk. Hab ich gedacht, verdammt ist das eine schwierige Vorbereitung. Weil da stehen ganz viele Mannschaften oben, wo ich Angst vor genau dieser Frage habe, warum stehen die da? Und meine Antwort ist, die haben ein paar mal gut gespielt, die haben ein paar mal schlecht gespielt, jetzt stehen sie da.
Ja gut, aber dann ist doch die Antwort eigentlich, es ist die berühmte Momentaufnahme. Man kann es noch nicht sagen.
Genau, also ich kann es jetzt nicht offen gesagt, ich weiß nicht, warum Angers da oben steht. Ich habe sie nämlich gesehen, habe ich sie live – also nicht live, im Fernsehen – beim Auftakt, glaube ich, bei 0 zu 6 gegen Lyon. Und da war Lyon großartig. Bonge, viertkleinstes Budget der Liga, haben sich gefreut, dass sie nur zwei Schlüsselspieler diese Saison verloren haben. Was ja auch schon einiges aussagt. Geringste Ballbesitzrate der Liga, also im Schnitt irgendwas unter 40 Prozent. Unter der englischen Woche hat ein Joker doppelt getroffen, alle Juli. Am Wochenende davor hat auch ein Anwechselspieler dreifach sogar getroffen gegen Saint Etienne. Also die Mannschaft wird geschlossen. Das zumindest kann man sagen. Obwohl, also die haben getroffen, obwohl die Mannschaften irgendwie auf 6 Positionen umgestellt worden sind. Ausgeglichen, ja. Zusammengewachsen, ja. Aber halt eine Kontermannschaft. Es ist schön, dass wir mal ein paar Sätze über sie verlieren können. Ich würde tippen, dass wir das beim nächsten Mal nicht mehr machen. Und wenn doch, dann muss ich mir dringend ein paar mehr Spiele von ihnen anschauen.
Also interessanterweise sind sie nach den Expected Points, wo ja so ein bisschen versucht wird, der Zufall rauszurechnen. Wären sie jetzt auch auf Platz 3 hinter Lille, also hätten sie auch eine ganz gute Bilanz, allerdings dann schon drei Punkte weniger als jetzt. Und sie haben immerhin, trotz des wenigen Ballbesitzes, die fünf meistens Schüsse in Richtung des gegnerischen Tores. Also das klingt für mich nach Umschaltfußball. Und dann warten wir einfach ab, David. Wir werden noch häufiger über Lille Ligue 1 sprechen und dann können wir uns noch ausführlicher damit befassen. Mit Lille habe ich ja aber auch schon den Drittplatzierten genannt. Das ist so ein bisschen der einzige, neben PSG, der einzige Verein, der im letzten Jahr unter den Top 4 lag, der auch noch annähernd jetzt dort zu Hause ist. Also wir werden über Lyon und Etienne sehr viel später in diesem Kurzpass sprechen. Die hatten einen fürchterlichen Start in die Saison. Ist das jetzt unspektakulär, was dabei Lille passiert ist mit den vier Siegen, einem Unentschieden und zwei Niederlagen? Oder gibt es darüber Worte zu verlieren?
Auch gar nicht so viel. Also man muss dazu ja sagen, Lille war definitiv die Mannschaft der Vor-Saison. Wir haben sie ja wirklich auch ausführlich gewürdigt. Zu Recht auch. Ich glaube, ohne diese Paris-Catamillionen hätte das ein ganz wunderbarer Meister werden können. Sie haben Pepe verloren an Arsenal, das hat man, glaube ich, mitbekommen. Sie haben einen ihrer wichtigsten Mittelspieler verloren an Lyon. Wir haben ja auch gesagt, wie das Mittelfeld sehr entscheidend dafür war, dass sie den Wundersturm so schön zaubern konnte. Sie haben aktuell vorne drin einen Spieler, den man durchaus mal weiter beobachten kann, Ossi Menn, der mal bei Wolfsburg gespielt hat, ein paar Einsätze. Allerdings so unauffällig, dass ich zumindest ihn nicht beachte. Ich wusste das noch nicht mal, dass er bei Wolfsburg war. 14 Bundesligaspieler anscheinend, fast alles Einwechslung.
Der jetzt schon sechs Mal getroffen hat in der Liga.
Genau, der jetzt die Überraschung des Saisonstarts ist.
Also er jagt den Rekord von Gerd Müller, würde man hier in Deutschland sagen.
Der auch anscheinend schon vor seinem Wechsel zu Wolfsburg beobachtet wurde von diversen Clubs. Also er ist erst 20, wohlgemerkt. Und das wiederum ist, glaube ich, ein ganz spannender Faktor, den man nicht genug betonen kann. Nämlich das Scouting, was Lille gerade macht, das ja von Lewis Campos maßgeblich betreut wird, obwohl er keinen offiziellen Posten bei Lille hat. Aber so der virtuelle Schatten, sportliche Leiter ist. Und das war ja auch der Architekt der Meisterschaftsmannschaft von Monaco, muss man ja auch klar sagen. Also der hat James entdeckt, der hat Fabinho entdeckt. Der hat jetzt für Lille unter anderem Seki Selig, den Türken geholt, 22 Rechtsverteidiger, Marktwert aktuell unter 20 Millionen. Er hat jetzt noch einen türkischen Spieler geholt, Yusuf Yiqi, auch 22, der junge Timothy Ware ist gekommen aus Paris. Also da sollte man in den nächsten Jahren ein sehr gutes Auge drauf werfen, glaube ich, wer alles zu Lille kommt. Da habe ich großes Vertrauen in diese Strukturen.
Da ist mir auch ein Name aufgefallen, ziemlich unbekannt, wird kaum jemand von gehört haben. Renato Sanches, das scheint ein junger Portugieser zu sein, hat aber noch nicht so wahnsinnig viel gespielt.
Nee, aber könnte genauso diese... Hat, glaube ich, auch so eine Vergangenheit, dass er nicht so richtig zum Zug kam bei seinem alten Verein.
Du, weiß ich nicht, das habe ich nicht so genau im Blick gehabt. Als süddeutsche Systempresse finde ich es gut, dass er jetzt nicht mehr in der Bundesliga spielt. Also, Ozymen macht seine Buden und Lille scoutet sehr gut.
Genau, genau. Also, Ozymen kann man durchaus mal beobachten. Läuft viel, gutes Augeverstellungsspiel.
Hat auch schon zwei Assists zu seinen 6 Toren hinzugefügt. Also, das ist schon sehr ordentlich.
Ich würde auch glauben, dass wir über Lille nochmal sprechen im Laufe der Saison.
Davon gehe ich auch schon fast aus.
Ich hoffe es auch eigentlich, dass da sich zumindest irgendjemand irgendwie oben etabliert.
Ja, also dahingehend ist die Ligue 1 schon auch eine interessante Liga. Bei aller Dominanz von PSG dahinter passiert schon so einiges. Unter anderem ja auch, dass ein FC Nantes aktuell auf Platz 4 liegt, mit einer sensationellen Tordifferenz von 7 zu 5 Toren. Das riecht nach Spektakel. Wie geil ist es? So eine Frage wollte ich schon immer mal stellen.
Es ist vor allem überraschend, weil mit Gorküff ein Trainer kam, den man jetzt überhaupt nicht erwartet hätte. Das ist jemand, der eigentlich Zeit für Ideen braucht. Auch das hatte ich letztes Mal schon erwähnt. Wir haben da mit Valdemar Kita einen Präsidenten, der Trainern überhaupt keine Zeit gibt, irgendwas zu etablieren. Das ist jetzt der 13. Trainer in zwölf Jahren. Und der 6. seit 2016. Genau. Wir hatten ja, glaube ich, letzte Folge hatte ich gerade noch erzählt, dass Halil Hucic gekommen war, der auch als Sturkopf galt, und dass das potentiell krachen könnte. Es hat dann die ganze Saison nicht gekracht, sondern es hat schon gekracht wegen der Rückrunde. Und eine Woche vor Saison begangen wurde Halil Hucic dann entlassen. Nond hat sich ganz viele Abfuhren geholt, mehrere Trainer sollen abgewunken haben. Und dann kam Gorküff und du fragst dich, was wollen die jetzt genau mit dem, der ist damals in Rennen entlassen worden. Im Zuge der großen Umstrukturierung, obwohl er viel Siege in Folge gemacht hatte, nimmt das in der Rennen nach wie vor unglaublich übel. Das Witzige an ihm, warum er jetzt bei Nond ist, ist, dass er vermehrt versucht hat, bei verschiedenen Vereinen immer sein Jeux à la Nantes zu etablieren. Und das fand meistens keinen Anklang. Also den Nond-Stil. Und wir sind ja ein Bildungspodcast hier. Ich kläre mal ganz kurz auf, der Nond-Stil, Jeux à la Nantes, wurde 60er, 70er gespielt. Also starke Laufleistung, Zonenverteidigung, Abseitsfalle, viel Rhythmusänderung. Und wird heute als Begriff allgemein benutzt für ein Team, wie so fluides Spiel und Positionswechsel, One-Touch und so was. Und das wirkte nicht so, als sei das jetzt das Richtige für Nond. Also zumindest nicht im 21. Jahrhundert als Mannschaft. Aber aktuell funktioniert's. Also wohlgemerkt auch, basierend auf einer starken Defensive, hat einen ganz netten taktischen Kniff gemacht, indem er Girotto vom Defensiv-Mittelfeld in die Innenverwaltung gestellt hat. Und dadurch jetzt so eine Art unverhofften Neuzugang hat. Und aktuell präsentieren die Spielfreude, Entspanntheit, inklusive des Trainers. Das, obwohl sie Rangier abgeben müssten. Ein ganz wichtiger Spieler, Kapitän, der in so einer Transfer-Posse nach Marseille gewechselt ist. Am Deadline ist er nicht gewechselt. Bis Mitternacht. Er sollte wechseln bis Mitternacht und ist da nicht gewechselt. Aber es gibt in Frankreich eine Joker-Regelung, wo du nach dem Verstreichen der Transfer-Fensters noch einmal wechseln darfst innerhalb der Liga.
Was denken sich denn diese Verbände? Als würdest du ein Gesellschaftsspiel machen. Als Joker ist er dann nach dem Deadline, die ja gar keine wirkliche Deadline ist, ist er dann noch gewechselt. Ich lerne hier tatsächlich viel in den Folgen mit dir. Also, Nord, das könnte sich noch einpegeln. 3-1-0-Siege in den sieben Spielen bisher nach Expected Points übrigens irgendwo auf Platz 15. Also da sieht man schon, man hat auch das Optimale rausgeholt aus dem schönen Spiel, was man da spielen möchte. Und man tritt so nach dem, was ich sehe, auch mit einer relativ klaren Stammformation an. Also da scheint Gorky für jetzt auch einfach auf das zu setzen, was er glaubt zu haben. Und aktuell funktioniert das gut, könnte sich aber noch einpegeln.
Ja, trotz 14 Abgänge, 10 Neuverpflichtungen.
Gut, Nord, auf Platz 4. Dahinter wartet jetzt eine weitere Mannschaft, die es halbwegs geschafft hat, sich oben zu halten. Jetzt normalisiert sich ein bisschen die Tabelle. Wir wollen kurz über Bordeaux sprechen. Was gibt es da festzuhalten? Was für einen Saisonstart hatten die?
Einen einfachen.
Also vom Spielplan her einfach.
Also grüße an meinen 93 Kollegen Axel, der mit mehr drüber streitet.
Spielpläne völlig überbewertet.
Spielpläne wichtig sind, genau. Die letzten vier Spiele gegen Dijon, Metz, Brest und Amiens. Und das sind jetzt alles nicht Namen, wo man unbedingt… Also das sind Namen, wo man durchaus erwarten kann, dass man gewinnt. Auch wenn das manche nicht geschafft haben, schon auch größere Namen. Und zum Auftrag haben sie gegen Oranger verloren. Das Wichtigste bei Bordeaux ist – oder vielleicht auch für ausländische Zuhörer – ist halt, dass sie Koschelli geholt haben von Arsenal, der sicherlich in der Spieleröffnung nochmal einiges beizutragen hat. Ansonsten haben ja auch jetzt so ein Investoren-Konglomerat ein neues, die angekündigt hatten, Ziel sei Top 6. Es gibt aktuell so ein bisschen Zweifel, ob das tatsächlich ein Top-Six-Kader ist. Daraufhin sagte dann im Sommer der eine Vorsitzende, Joe da Großer, wir haben einige großartige Leute im Visier. Die Bordeaux-Variante von, wenn ihr wüsstet, wen wir schon alles haben.
Und was genauso krass wie hier in Deutschland. Wenn ich mir angucke, dass man insgesamt nur 7 Millionen investiert hat, dann sind da entweder bei den zurückgekehrten Leihspielen richtige Granaten mit dabei oder man konnte das nicht so ganz halten.
Es kam halt Koscielny als Name. Der Rest waren ablösefreie Spieler. Max Herr ist jetzt vielleicht eine ganz gute Idee für Innenverteidigung. Ja, also nein, tatsächlich, es kam halt nicht viel.
Das heißt, die Investoren haben ja auch gar nicht investiert, wenn ich mir angucke. Ich nehme jetzt alle Daten von transfermarkt.de. 7 Millionen Ausgaben, 34 Millionen Einnahmen, das heißt eher ein Transfer Plus gemacht. Hört sich jetzt nicht so an, als hätte man da Geld reingesteckt, um ja so ein bisschen den Turnaround zu schaffen. In der letzten Saison Bordeaux ja auf Platz 14 eingelaufen.
Genau, Trainer ist auch sehr unzufrieden. Trainer übrigens, Paulo Souza, habe ich das schon mal erwähnt?
Ja, ja, hat mir schon mal kurz darüber gesprochen.
Ist ja aus der großen Dortmunder Mannschaft in den 90ern. Ja, genau. Ja, jetzt unter der Woche hat der junge Adli, war Doppeltorschützer gegen Amir, 19 Jahre alt, kam schon im Winter, saß die ganze Zeit auf der Bank, kam nicht so rechtlich rein, war ein bisschen unzufrieden, hat jetzt in zwei Spielen richtig stark aufgedreht. Also vielleicht kann man den ein bisschen beobachten.
Aber ehrlich gesagt hört sich das jetzt für mich von außen betrachtet so an, als wenn ich jetzt Bordeaux-Fan wäre, dann wäre die kurze Begeisterung darüber, jetzt vielleicht mit Investoren neue Möglichkeiten zu haben, schon wieder ganz schön verflogen. Auch wenn natürlich aktuell die Tabelle gut aussieht. Aber als Bordeaux-Fan könnte ich ja auch den Spielplan lesen.
Das geht einigen so in Frankreich. Dass sie lesen können. Dass sie nicht so ganz wissen, ob sie so glücklich sein sollten über die großen Investoren. Auch Marseille unter anderem.
Eine goldene Überleitung zu unserem Sechsplatzierten.
Haben nämlich auch wenig investiert. Da haben auch die Fans das Gefühl, dass McCourt ein bisschen das Interesse verloren hat. Und außerdem haben sie ganz große Bilanzminusse. Also wurscht. Jedenfalls haben sie 18 und 19 jeweils mit rund minus 18 Millionen abgeschlossen. Haben deswegen in der Vorsaison gesagt, wir müssen unbedingt verkaufen und jeder steht zum Verkauf. Woraufhin dann einige Spieler sich gemeldet haben und gesagt haben, wir wollen nicht gehen, wir wollen gerne bleiben. Das war ganz amüsant zuzuschauen. Am Ende ging es auch auf Campus zu Sevilla und Louis Gustavo zu Finnebacce. Das war jetzt auch nicht unbedingt der große Verkauf. Dafür kamen immerhin zwei interessante Spieler, nämlich Benedetto von Boca Juniors und eben wie gesagt, wie eben schon angesprochen, Ranjier, der Ex-Kapitän von Nantes. Insofern könnte Benedetto endlich der Stürmer sein, den Marseille jahrelang nicht so richtig hatte. Macht einen ganz guten Eindruck bislang. Die andere große Geschichte ist natürlich Willis Boas als Trainer. Das ist ja auch immerhin mal ein Name. Er hat zu Saisonbrücken gesagt, er weiß, Restriktion schwierig und so, aber der Kader hat trotzdem Top 3 Potenzial.
Potenzial, aber auch das Potenzial zu einem Weltklasse-Podcast. Aber wenn ich mir dann angucke, Benedetto immerhin schon viermal getroffen, jetzt in sechs Einsätzen in der Liga, aber insgesamt die Tordifferenz, acht geschossene Tore, sieben kassierte Tore, daraus zwölf Punkte gemacht. Also effizient sind sie schon, aber noch nicht spektakulär. Und das klingt jetzt auch noch nicht nach Top 3.
Nee, also die Mannschaft ist in der Erfindungsphase. Garcia wurde zuletzt dafür kritisiert, dass er das Spiel zu sehr nach dem Gegner einrichtet. Man freut sich jetzt darauf, dass Villas-Boas wieder sich mehr auf die Mannschaft konzentriert, dem mehr Selbstvertrauen eingibt. Du siehst zuerst die Andeutungen von dem, was er wohl vorhat. Also Ballbesitz, wenig Flanken, was dich freuen wird. Thauvin hat sich jetzt verletzt auf unbestimmte Zeit. Das ist natürlich schon ein Schlag. Ansonsten darf ich noch mal Liebe für Valère Jarmain aussprechen, den ich jetzt auch beobachtet habe beim Sieg von Massé, beim unglaublich verrückten 4 zu 3 gegen Monaco.
Das gehört eben noch dazu zu diesen 8 geschossenen und 7 kassierten Toren, dass man allein 4 davon geschossen hat gegen Monaco und 3 kassiert gegen Monaco. Also die sonstigen Ergebnisse waren 0-2, 0-0, 1-0 und so weiter.
Du merkst schon, wir sind jetzt schon in Regionen, wie ich es vorhin gesagt habe, von Teams, die haben mal gut gespielt und haben mal schlecht gespielt. Und so richtig kann ich keinen Muster erkennen bei vielen Teams. Jetzt auch gerade als jemand, der nicht alle Spiele schaut, der aktuell auch gar nicht mehr alle Spiele schauen kann. Danke Datsen, die aktuell ihre nur noch, glaube ich, 3-4 Spiele pro Spieltag ausstrahlen. Das war letzte Saison besser. Aber wie gesagt, Valère Germain mochte ich damals bei Monaco schon. Ist ein sehr altruistischer Arbeiterstürmer, der braucht eigentlich einen klassischen Mittelstürmer neben sich. Wurde dann teilweise ein bisschen verheizt, als sollte vorne spielen, konnte das nicht. Hatte mit Metro Club jetzt auch nicht unbedingt jemanden neben sich, der die große Bombe ist. Und gegen Monaco ist er nach außen gezogen worden. Also auch ganz taktischer Kniff eigentlich. Saar wurde zurückgezogen als Außenverteidiger. Und Germain wurde stattdessen auf die Außenposition gesetzt. Und zog aber häufig nach innen und hat da richtig schön genetzt. Freut mich für ihn, dass er da vielleicht noch mal Licht blickt.
Ja, also da ist schon wirklich Potenzial vorhanden. Wenn man sich den Kader anguckt, eben jetzt auch mit Benedetto dazu, dann hättest du eben so jemanden. Du hast Kevin Strootmann noch dann im zentralen Mittelfeld. Also es ist ein relativ kleiner Kader, 26 Spieler. Da darf jetzt auch nicht allzu viel passieren für Olympique Marseille. Aber mal gucken, wie sich das findet und wie das dann weitergeht in den nächsten Jahren.
Ja, und ob es halt zusammen – also ob es auch Vila Spor ist, es halt schafft, sich auch zu etablieren.
Ich meine, es hilft natürlich, dass du keine Doppelbelastung hast. Es ist schmerzhaft, aber da kann sich sowas eher noch einspielen. Hinter Marseille liegt aktuell NHL mit einer ausgeglichenen Tordifferenz. 11 kassierte, 11 geschossene Tore, 4 Siege, 3 Niederlagen. Was gibt es zu NHL zu sagen?
Na ja, zunächst mal auch wieder die große Investoren-Sache. Da kommen wir jetzt auch nicht drum rum. Ich weiß, du magst das nicht gerne, aber…
Nein, eigentlich finde ich das ja gut, weil das sind so viele gute Beispiele, wo man immer wieder seine eigenen Gedanken für die Bundesliga haben kann. In die eine oder in die andere Richtung.
Ja, also in Nähe aus ist eingestiegen. Jim Redcliffe, Reichstermann Englands, geschätzte 10 Milliarden Euro Privatvermögen. Das kann man mal im Vergleich aufziehen. Also Rübo Loftleff, der Chef von Monaco, kommt auf nur 6 Milliarden. McCourt in Marseille kommt gerade mal auf 1 Milliarde. Ist aber trotzdem in der Liga nur auf Rang 2 hinter der Familie. Also bei Privatvermögen, wir rechnen jetzt die Kataris raus.
So wie der katarische Staat organisiert ist, würde ich natürlich auch von den Privatvermögen sprechen. Aber okay, meinetwegen.
Familie Pinot, denen Rennen gehört, die haben einen Privatvermögen von 26 Milliarden. Also denen gehören so Luxusmarken wie Yves Saint Laurent und Gucci und so was.
Das heißt, sie verdienen auch mit dem Fußball auch noch an der Konsumentenseite sehr gut. Sie investieren nicht nur in den Fußball, sondern sie verkaufen auch ihre Tässchen und ihre Kleidung an die Fußballer.
Aber wir wollten ja eigentlich über Nizza sprechen. Das Witzigste ist, dass tatsächlich in diesem Fall, im Gegensatz zu anderen Investoren, der Kauf von Fans sehensüchtig erwartet wurde, auch eine große, große Sommergeschichte für Sommerloch. Wann kommt endlich der Kauf? Wann wird er endlich vollzogen? Weil halt vorher war halt so ein chinesisch-amerikanisches Konsortium da, die man gar nicht loswerden wollten. Die haben es für 23 Millionen damals gekauft, haben es jetzt für 100 Millionen an Radcliffe verkauft. Ka-Ching. Haben also ihr Geld gemacht. Führte unter anderem auch dazu, dass halt kaum Transfers getätigt worden sind, weil nicht klar war, wer kommt da jetzt, wo ist das Geld. Und sie haben jetzt wirklich auf den letzten Drücker ihre Neuzugänge eingetütet. Das jetzt aber dann wiederum ganz ordentlich, wobei es halt alles junge Leute sind. Also Dolberg ist gekommen. Genau, Dolberg ist gekommen von Ajax. Unaz, ganz spannender rechts außen. Claude Maurice, ebenfalls sehr interessanter links außen von Lorient. Nsochi von Paris. Also das ist nach wie vor eine Jugendmannschaft. Auch das galt ja letztes Jahr schon. Es gilt umso mehr. Das Kuriose an diesem ganzen Investoren-Hin-und-Her-Gewechsel ist die Auswirkung auf und für Viera als Trainer. Weil der wurde ursprünglich von dem vorigen Führungspersonal geholt. Rivere und Fournier. Und die hatten sich mit den Investoren zerstritten. Die sind gegangen. Und der hatte sich noch den Vertrag schreiben lassen. Naja, falls die gehen müssen, dann darf er auch gehen. Weil er möchte mit denen zusammenbleiben. Und dann ging es aber freiwillig. Weil es ihm zwar von den Fans hoch angerechnet wurde, aber auch dazu geführt hat, dass er sich im Stich gelassen gefühlt hat. Und jetzt wurde spekuliert, was heißt das jetzt, wenn die wieder zurückkommen. Also für ihn. Der hat sich ziemlich kritisch über sie geäußert, dass sie das Schiff verlassen haben zwischendrin. Und sind jetzt wieder zurückgekommen.
Da bin ich jetzt an einem Punkt gedanklich ausgestiegen. Wir sprechen jetzt hier über die sportliche Leitung.
Genau, also Präsidenten und Sportdirektoren.
Genau, und die sind gegangen, sind gegangen und kommen jetzt aber wieder zurück.
Genau, haben hingeschmissen, weil sie von den alten Investoren sich nicht angemessen oder schützgefühlt haben.
Jetzt bin ich wieder bei dir. Und weil sie das freiwillig gemacht haben, konnte er nicht mitkommen.
Und Radcliffe hat jetzt gesagt, dann holen wir sie wieder zurück. Sie haben sogar, wenn ich mir richtig in den Sinn nehme, dass sie Radcliffe gerufen haben. Der soll doch nach meinem Auge drauf schauen und wäre das nicht was für ihn. Sie haben ihn quasi geholt und dann war auch klar, dass sie wieder mit einsteigen. Also ziemlich abstruse Sache, die mir so als ehemaliger Politikwissenschaftler ja fast schon Spaß macht.
Ja klar, es gab auf jeden Fall ein sehr interessantes, erstes Kick-off-Meeting. Schön, dass ihr wieder da seid. Aber Nizza, hochspannende Mannschaft, jüngster Kader der Liga, im Durchschnitt 23 Jahre jung. Du hast ja auch schon angesprochen, auch die Zugänge, alle sehr jung und talentiert. Und was ich bisher über Patrick Vieira als Trainer gelesen habe, hat sich auch sehr positiv angehört. Also es könnte jetzt auch trotz der Umstände, wie es dazu kam, auch ein ganz guter Match sein zwischen Trainer und Kader.
Ja, ich mache eine Einschränkung. Letzte Saison war es, glaube ich, der drittschlechteste Angriff der Liga. Also das hatten wir auch schon mal besprochen. Vieira spielt halt defensiv.
30 Tore in 38 Spielen war das letztes Jahr.
Ja, genau. Und das ist so ein klein bisschen schade eigentlich. Ich sage nicht, dass Trainer sich nicht weiterentwickeln können. Mal schauen, weil da ist unglaublich viel Potenzial. Und da sind ganz viele echt spannende Leute. Mal sehen. Also sie haben ein paar Spiele gut und ein paar Spiele schlecht. Ich hatte sie zuletzt eben gegen Monaco gesehen. Da waren sie schlecht. Da kommen wir vielleicht, wenn wir noch ein bisschen auf die Tube drücken. Über Monaco müssen wir noch kurz sprechen. Das war das erste gute Spiel von Monaco insofern.
Okay, aber da könnte auch was entstehen bei Nizza. Wir verfolgen das genau wie ihr. Definitiv eine interessante Persönlichkeit. Jetzt kommen wir noch zu zwei Mannschaften, über die wir sprechen wollen, wo ich bei der Aussprache ganz genau unterscheiden muss. Wir wollen erst über Stade Rennes sprechen und dann über Stade Rennes. Ah, Rennes, das siehst du, das ist ja eindeutig. Also, Stade Rennes ist aktuell mit nur zwei Gegentreffern. Damit beste Defensive der Liga.
Unglaubliches Torverhältnis.
6 zu 2 ist das Torverhältnis.
Nach sieben Spielen.
Das ist halt wie so ein erster Satz im Tennis.
Also, zu Rasenfunk einfach ganz kurz, ganz viel Liebe für Rennes nach diesem siebten Spieltag wegen diesem Sieg gegen PSG. Haben vorher auch schon Marseille und Lille geschlagen. Haben eine starke Defensive einfach um Abdelhamid, der ein sehr unterschätzter Innenverteidiger ist, wohlgemerkt. Und dem Jungen, die sah sie davor, so zwei Abräumer mit Chavalera und Montesi. Und der spannende Typ, auf dem man – ne, eins ist zwei – also du hast zwei spannende Sturmtalente bei Ras, auf die du einfach in den nächsten Monaten, in die jemand in den nächsten Monaten Auge werfen soll. Es haben ganz viele Leute schon Augen drauf geworfen. Das ist Rémi Oudin, der schon fast hätte wechseln können diesen Sommer. Und jetzt Bolaidia, mit einem sensationellen Falldruckzieher in der Nachspielzeit gegen Paris, hat das 2-0 eingeleitet. Und das Witzige an Dia ist eigentlich seine Entwicklung zum Profi-Spieler. Der war vor zwei Jahren noch in der siebten Liga.
Ah, der Niklas Völkruck der Ligue 1.
So ungefähr. Und als er elf Jahre war, sollte er mal bei Saint-Étienne vorspielen. Und dann hatte das Auto seines Vaters auf dem Weg eine Panne. Und der Vater war so verärgert, dass er Taxi gerufen hat, dass wir mit dem Taxi zurückgefahren sind. Also nicht zu Saint-Étienne, sondern zurück nach Hause. Das heißt, erster Einstieg in den Profi-Fußball schon mal verpasst. Dann sollte er vier Jahre später bei Lyon aufgenommen werden in der Akademie und wurde abgelehnt, weil er nicht die richtige Statur hat. Also zweiter Einstieg in den Profi-Fußball verpasst. Dann erkrankte sein Vater, die hat eine Ausbildung gemacht, um die Familie über Wasser zu halten. Und ja, ungefähr vor zwei, drei Jahren ist er dann explodiert und hat angeblich irgendwie Bällen alleine den ganzen Platz hinterher gejagt und das Tor noch geschossen. Und beim ersten Freundschaftsspiel gegen Ras, Quatsch, Führers, hat er nach 45 Sekunden getroffen. Also ist ein junger, erfrischender Typ, der auch ganz anders auftritt, vielleicht weil er nicht durch Akademien gegangen ist, sehr spannend. Ist nicht Stammstürmer aktuell, wird häufig auch eingewechselt, aber das macht einfach Laune.
Das hört sich so an. Und ich habe natürlich Hendrik Weidand gemeint, nicht Niklas Völkruck. Da will man einen Gag reinwerfen und versemmet ihn dann auch noch. Und sie haben einen Philipp Lahm-endlichen Spieler im Kader mit Hassan Kamara, der 1.68 groß ist und auf der linksverteidiger Position, nach dem, was ich so sehe, bisher auch ganz gute Spiele gemacht hat.
Der ein Tor gemacht hat gegen Paris, mit einem Kopfball.
Klar, warum auch nicht.
Ja, die großen, die standen so große Innenverteidigungen herum, und er springt hoch mit seinen 1.68 und schießt das 1.0 großartig.
Ja, man merkt schon ein bisschen die Liebe für dieses 2.0, die merkt man dir schon an bei PSG. Lass uns über Startrennen noch sprechen, den Pokalsieger der Liga dahinter. Was gibt's da zu sagen?
Haben wir die Zeit noch, so was überspringen? Also eigentlich kommen wir jetzt den zwei Mannschaften, von denen ich gedacht hatte, dass ich über sie sprechen könnte ausführlich, weil Rennes und Lyon waren die beiden großen. Also die haben richtig Freude gemacht zum Saisonstart. Und bei Rennes ein bisschen überraschend, weil die Hälfte der Mannschaft, die den Pokal gewonnen hat, ist gewechselt. Also Sarre ist weg, Kubek ist zu Augsburg, Ben Affa, Cefane Andre ist zu Lille und so weiter. So und trotzdem haben sie in den ersten drei Spielen ein Feuerwerk abgebrannt. Das war unglaublich. Das war der heiße Shit der Liga. Und inmitten all dessen Kammer Winger. 16-jähriger Spieler, der beim Sieg gegen PSG alleine das Mittelfeld von Paris ausgedribbelt hat. Furchtlos, unverfroren, technisch großartig, Auge für Vorlagen. Ich habe ihn zufälligerweise dann ein, zwei Wochen später live im Stadion gegen Straßburg gesehen, also tatsächlich live. Ich war in Straßburg und habe mir das Ligaspiel Straßburg Rennen angeschaut. Und auch da war er auffällig. Er hat fast schon so einen leichten Tick, dass er ständig manisch den Kopf dreht und nach allen Seiten Ausschau hält. Das wirkte auf mich ein bisschen übertrieben, aber es zeigt, glaube ich, auch, wie wichtig ihm Spielübersicht ist.
Und er spielt eben im defensiven Mittelfeld, nicht im offensiven Mittelfeld. Also er hat diese Offensivaktion, diese Dribblings, aber sie kommen aus einer tiefen Position heraus.
Und er ist offenbar schon seit einigen Monaten auf dem Allradlager aus der Clubs, aber spätestens seit diesem Paris-Spiel, glaube ich, wahrscheinlich bei allen drauf. Er ist in Angola geboren, der französische Verband versucht, derzeit ihn möglichst schnell einzubürgern, weil die Nationalmannschaft hat ja so wenig Talente.
Wo ist da eigentlich der DFB?
Genau, so. Also das war der Saisonauftakt von Rennes und alles war super. Und jetzt, seitdem dümpeln sie vor sich hin. Könnte daran liegen, dass sie jetzt zum Transferfenster, das ja sehr, sehr spät war, noch mal drei Neue geholt haben. Die waren, z.B. beim 1 gegen Celtic, waren ja alle auf dem Platz, da fehlte ganz viel Abstimmung.
Also eine Mannschaft im Umbruch, 22 Zugänge, 22 Abgänge, durchwachsene Saison bisher, mit aber ihren Spitzen nach oben und eben mit Kammerwinger, deinem 16-Jährigen im Mittelfeld, auf dem man definitiv ein Auge bringt.
Ja, und ich habe nach wie vor ganz, ganz viel Vertrauen in Julian Stefan als Trainer, der ja letztes Jahr einen großartigen Job gemacht hat. Ich glaube, der kriegt die auch wieder zusammen. Der muss jetzt wahrscheinlich auch mal mit denen arbeiten und dann kommen sie hoffentlich wieder nach vorne.
Und Rennen kann man ja auch in der Europa League beobachten. Da gab es jetzt schon ein 1 zu 1 gegen Celtic zu Hause. Die weiteren Gegner in der Gruppe sind noch Lazio und Cluj. Also durchaus, ich glaube, von Rennen werden wir noch was sehen, auch international.
Ja, glaube ich auch, hoffe ich auch.
Das bekommt man. Dann müssen wir definitiv noch über Lyon sprechen. Denn die waren in der letzten Saison auf Tabellenplatz 3 hinter Lille und PSG, jetzt aktuell auf Tabellenplatz 11 und ohne jetzt den Tabellenplatz über bewerten zu wollen. Aber drei Unentschieden und zwei Niederlagen bei sieben Spielen. Das ist schon ordentlich. Wo hakt es denn bei Lyon?
Möglicherweise am Trainer. Die Story ist, dass es nach zwei Spieltagen so aussah, als seien sie der große Herausforderung für Paris dieses Jahr. Ich habe es gerade vorhin schon erwähnt. Ich habe das 6-0 gegen Eugé gesehen. Das war atemberaubend guter Fußball und seitdem treten sie auf der Stelle. Also der Spielaufbau ist schlecht. Die Spieler scheinen zarkhaft, die Defensive scheinen nicht so recht, mit der Offensive zusammenzuarbeiten, was insofern ein bisschen überraschend ist, weil das das große Versprechen war, dass vor der Saison im Raum stand, dadurch, dass Fekir zu Betis gewechselt ist. Hier ist es A, dann kann der neue Trainer endlich sein geplantes 4-3-3 besser aufziehen. Das hätte mit Fekir nicht so gut gepasst. Und dann ist da ein stärkerer Block vorhanden. Die haben auch – also das ist auch nach wie vor eine großartige Mannschaft. Die haben ein unglaubliches Talent in der Offensive. Die haben Moussa Dembélé, Bernard Traoré, Memphis Depay. Im Mittelfeld hast du mit Hussein Aoua, ein Spieler, der absolut großartig zu Saisonbeginn war, den ich hier eigentlich als großes Talent jetzt loben müsste. Nur ich kam gar nicht auf die Idee im Vorfeld, weil ich dachte, naja, der ist jetzt seit drei Jahren da. Ich glaube, vor zwei Jahren habe ich dem als Talent gelobt. Der ist 21. Aber er ist ein großartiger Achter mit Spielgefühl und Ballgefühl. Er nutzt auch seine Antritte mehr in letzter Zeit. Also ein großartiger Typ. Einige tolle Leute haben auch gut verpflichtet. Thiago Mendes von Lille, Anderson für die Innenverteidigung.
Schöne Lied, ein bisschen leer gekauft, mit Mendes und Coney. Jemand von dem Team, was einen Platz höher war in der letzten Saison.
Die zweite große Änderung ist der Trainer und Sportdirektor, weil Juninho ist zurück. Juninho ist der große Mythos für Lyon. 344 Spiele.
Könnte man den nicht für den ein oder anderen Freistoß in der Nachspielzeit einwechseln?
44 Freistöße. Gab es nicht auch irgendeinen Berühmten gegen Bayern?
Kann ich mich nicht daran erinnern. Ich bin süddeutsches Medium. Ich kann mich an Gegentreffer gegen FC Bayern grundsätzlich nicht erinnern. Aber gehört er zu dieser ganz großen Zeit von Lyon mit dazu?
Genau, zu der ganz großen Zeit und macht einen ganz guten Eindruck als sportlicher Leiter. Und dazu wurde neben ihm eben Silvino als Trainer geholt, der mir vorher kein Begriff war, muss ich sagen. Der auch anscheinend kein Französisch spricht. Das ist die zweite interessante Änderung. Vorher hat Präsident Olaß, der große Mann in Lyon, immer täglich beim Trainer angerufen, dass sich gewisse Trainer unter Druck gesetzt gefühlt haben. Und Silvino hat jetzt gesagt, ne, der Herr Harte hat sich bei mir noch nicht gemeldet.
Es ist ein interessanter Mann, weil er bisher noch nie als Cheftrainer fungiert. Er war bei Inter Mailand Co-Trainer, er war bei Brasilien Techniktrainer. Die Brasilianer haben ja große Defizite der Technik, das weiß ja jeder, da muss man noch mal nachlegen. Und jetzt erst der Cheftrainer-Position, also durchaus eine interessante Verpflichtung.
Ja, aber kam durchaus mit ein bisschen Vorschlusslorbeeren, hat ja bei Mailand unter Mancini oder neben Mancini gecoacht. Man merkt auch an, dass er Ideen hat, aber er lässt seine Außenverteidiger derzeit sehr, sehr defensiv auflaufen. Also offenbar tatsächlich auf Vorgabe. Es gab keine einzige Vorlage meines Wissens diese Saison von einem Außenverteidiger. Er erwartet sehr, sehr lange mit Wechseln. Beim Spiel gegen Amiens war das auch vielleicht. Da hat er in der 80. Minute drei neue Spiele eingewechselt.
Aber es ist so ein bisschen zwiespältig, oder? Auf der anderen Seite, jetzt in der Champions League, da ist Lyon ja auch vertreten, gegen Zenit zu Hause 1 zu 1. Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, hatte man da nicht noch die Möglichkeit aus 2 zu 1, die man vergeben hat. Also es scheint für mich so zu sein, als wäre Lyon auch so eine Mannschaft, wo man sagen muss, es ist definitiv kein geglückter Saisonstart, aber eigentlich too early to call. Also müsste man jetzt noch warten, was der neue Trainer da eigentlich vorhat.
Es ist halt, wie gesagt, insofern enttäuschend, weil die ersten zwei Spiele so großartig aussahen. Seitdem stottern sie und dann merkst du jetzt doch, aha, es ist eben doch ein neuer Trainer und das muss ich alles irgendwie erst einspielen. Und vielleicht muss ich auch der Trainer erst noch mal finden und zurechtfinden. Und das ist halt ein bisschen schade, weil du echt das Gefühl hast, da steckt ganz, ganz viel unter dem Motor drin. Jetzt warten wir mal ab, wie es weitergeht. Aber das war schon die letzten Spieltage so ein bisschen enttäuschend. Jetzt sagen die Spieler, ja, und da entwickelt sich was und wir finden immer besser zusammen. Also diese üblichen Spielersprüche, die du halt hörst. Ich würde mich freuen, wenn sie eine gute Rolle spielen, aber sie sind halt auch schon – wie viele Punkte sind sie jetzt schon?
Auf Platz 11 aktuell, wenn man nach Expected Points guckt, dann sieht man da, steht Lyon ein bisschen besser da auf Tabellenplatz 5. Und wer da auch überraschend gut dasteht, ist Monaco nach Expected Points auf Platz 7. In der realen Tabelle hat sich zur letzten Saison nicht so viel getan. Und das ist in dem Fall ein sehr schlechtes Zeichen, denn man steht auf Tabellenplatz 18, was in der Ligue 1 mit 20 Vereinen der Relegationsplatz um den Abstieg wäre, ohne dass wir jetzt nach 7 Spielen so tun wollen. Als wäre das schon alles in Stein gemeißet. Aber wenn ich mir angucke, die Transfersalden in der Liga, dann sehe ich, dass Monaco 140 Millionen Euro investiert hat, 83 Millionen immerhin auch eingenommen durch Verkäufe. Aber man hat am meisten ausgegeben von allen 20 Ligue 1-Vereinen mit 42 Zugängen und 34 Abgängen. Das ist David.
Pletter Wahnsinn.
Das ist nicht mehr normal.
Nein, es ist auch, ich bin ja, ihr habt es ja schon mal erwähnt, ich bin ja Monaco-Sympathisant. Mein Cousin hat da ja Jugendmannschaft gespielt. Ich verfolge die ja wirklich mit einer gewissen Liebe auch. Aber du, also selbst als Fan hast du in den letzten Wochen und Monaten Schwierigkeiten, dieses Startelf zu benennen, weil du einfach gar nicht mehr weißt, wer da gerade spielt und wer da neu dazugekommen ist. Also es ist absolut verrückt. Die haben sich eine komplette Mannschaft neu gekauft.
Im Grunde zwei Mannschaften sogar.
Ja. Und teilweise richtig große Namen auch. Also mit Le Comte eigentlich ein super Torwart aus Montpellier, der jetzt richtig schlecht gespielt hat. Fabregas ist ein erschreckender Schatten seiner selbst. Der hat die Saison mit einer roten Karte begonnen und anschließend ist er schlechter geworden. Also in den ersten Saisonspielen konnte es auch darauf wetten, dass Monaco sich rot einfängt. Am dritten Spieltag kam es 2-0 gegen Niem geführt, dann gab es ein Rot gegen Jamerson und am Ende war es ein 2-2. Wahrscheinlich hätte ich jetzt vollkommen ratlos Kübel von Häme und Ärger ausgeschüttet, wenn jetzt nicht dieser siebte Spieltag gewesen wäre, wo sie halt gegen Nizza durchaus überzeugend gewonnen haben. Und zumindest in der Offensive sah das jetzt ganz ordentlich aus, was da Golovin, Ben Yedder und Slimani gemacht haben.
Erste Saison am siebten Spieltag.
Ben Yedder ist auch so ein überraschender Transfer, wo du denkst, so jemanden kriegst du eigentlich nicht. Der will anscheinend sich in Position bringen für das nächste Großturnier, für die Nationalmannschaft. Und hat da das Gefühl, dass er in Frankreich mehr gesehen wird als in Spanien.
Das ist ein Mittelstück, der von Sevilla kam, für alle diejenigen, die jetzt nicht gleich mit dem Namen Ben Yedder etwas anfangen können.
Bakayoko ist zurück aus der großen Meistermannschaft. Das zumindest ist, allerdings nur Gelin von Chelsea. Das freut einen. Aber ansonsten sind da so viele großartige Namen, die dann, sobald sie da sind, das ist so ein bisschen das HSV-Syndrom irgendwie, sobald sie da sind, funktioniert es nicht. Also Jadim ist auch hart angezählt, das merkt man auch, wenn man…
Zum Wider.
Ja, mal wieder, genau. Ich verfolge diverse Monaco-Fans auf Twitter und so. Und da ist nicht mehr viel Liebe für den einzigen Superhelden Jadim vorhanden.
Der ja schon mal entlassen war.
Genau.
Dann kam Thierry Henry und dann kam Jadam wieder mit zurück.
Kam Jadim zurück, genau. Ich bin sicher, das war ja jeweils mit Millionen Abfindungen verbunden, sowohl Jadim zu entlassen als auch Thierry Henry zu entlassen. Ich bin sicher, das wäre aktuell wieder der Fall. Also es ist ein Trauerspiel eigentlich. Es ist ein absolutes Trauerspiel, was mit dieser Mannschaft passiert, die ja eigentlich über Jahrzehnte für Spielkultur stand.
Und auch für ein gelungenes Scouting ja eigentlich durchaus. Also aus Monaco kamen ja häufig die Talente, die vorher nicht auf dem Radar der großen Vereine waren.
Wobei gesagt, in den letzten Jahren kamen sie unter anderem wegen Louis Campos. Und der ist eben jetzt bei Lidl. Also es ist nicht so, dass im Gottes Willen, Monaco war tatsächlich auch schon vorher durchaus eine Talentschmiede. Aber von den letzten Winter-Transfers, die geholt worden sind in Monaco, ist eigentlich nur Gessen Martins ein Erfolg. Der Rest ist entweder direkt wieder weitergegangen oder sitzt noch sinnlos auf der Bank rum. Tielemanns.
Der Kader ist krass. Also der Kader ist so, dass man in sich durchgeht und denkt, in einer Fußballsimulation könnte man durchaus mit Monaco spielen. Aber da ist es ja nicht so wie eine Realität, dass die dann schlechter sind als ihre Werte. Weil du hast mit Subasic ja eigentlich gerade verletzt, aber einen guten Torhüter, Benagio ist da der Ersatz.
Le Compte war eigentlich großartig für Montpellier jetzt. Subasic und Benagio sind ja beide so die etwas angezählten, älteren Torwart, die ich überzeugen konnte. Und Le Compte ist wirklich großartig. Also eigentlich war er.
Und dann hast du Kami Glick als Kapitän, den kennt man auch.
Auch ein fürchterlicher Schatten seiner selbst.
Eigentlich als Bollwerk, daneben Naldo. Wir alle wissen im Guten wie im Schlechten, was Naldo kann. Und so richtig Benjamin Hendricks, darf man nicht vergessen, von Leverkusen damals noch zu Monaco gewechselt. Hört man jetzt auch in Deutschland gar nichts mehr davon. Dann hast du eben Baka Joko zurückgeholt aus der Meisterschaft. Du hast Fabregas im Mittelfeld, Adrian Silva. Du hast Golovin. Wir alle wissen, wie viele Sprits der angezogen hat während der Weltmeisterschaft.
Er findet sich allerdings jetzt. Der war ja auch einer der großen Enttäuschungen nach seinem Transfer direkt. Und mittlerweile, also ich wage da noch keine, Schwalbe macht noch keinen Sommer. Aber so in den letzten Spielen, in den letzten Wochen, das sieht richtig gut aus gerade, was der auf den Platz bringt. Endlich.
Also es ist schon, es ist ein bisschen ein Mysterium. Ben Yedda haben wir schon angesprochen. Dann Jean-Claude Kevin Augustin ist von Rabah Leipzig noch zu Monaco gewechselt. Ohne dass ich jetzt sagen würde, der reiht sich da schon direkt neben Ben Yedda ein in der Hierarchie. Aber um zu zeigen, also Monaco war ja sehr aktiv auf dem Transfermarkt und das funktioniert mal wieder sehr, sehr wenig. Ein Sieg, drei Unentschieden, drei Niederlagen. Über Monaco werden wir auch wieder viel reden, David. Das nächste Mal werden wir dann auch noch über Saint Etienne sprechen. Die stehen aktuell auch nicht gut da, nämlich noch schlechter als Monaco. Und wir erinnern uns, in der letzten Saison waren die ja auf Tabellenplatz 4. Die sind gerade neunzehntelang. Aber alle können wir jetzt nicht besprechen. Ihr habt es gemerkt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, auch wenn man es immer nicht so glauben mag, auch in der Liga ist so viel passiert, dass man da locker mehrere Stunden drüber sprechen könnte. Ich bin froh, David, dass ich das immer mit dir machen kann in dieser schönen Runde. Und das hat, wie immer, großen Spaß gemacht. Danke dir, dass du mit dabei warst.
Sehr gerne. Und wie viel haben wir die Stunden jetzt gerissen?
3 Minuten, 4 Minuten. Wir laufen gerade in die vierte Minute rein. Das wird gerade noch so gehen. Das war David Frogier de Ponlevoy als at n'gungongvn auf Twitter. Und ihr hört natürlich 3.90. Da könnt ihr David zusammen mit den anderen drei Verrückten jede Woche hören. David, vielen Dank dir für deine Zeit. Und euch lieben Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Es geht dann weiter im Rasenfunk mit einer Schlusskonferenz zur Bundesliga. Und dann gibt es sicherlich auch bald den nächsten Kurzpass und hoffentlich auch Tribütengespräche.